[Music]
the NBA all-star game this would be well
indeed which got off to a bit of up how
should I say this
a bumpy starts that will recall that's
what we're calling it
when firm you decided to jazz up the
national anthem farm from Fergalicious
just look at the pained faces of celebs
and players alike the Twitter backlash
harsh Fergie slow mode jazzy national
anthem was basically labeled a star
mangled snoozefest and then this
happened Bob Saget tweeted it was
originally written by Francis Scott out
of key add to that this gift a bunch of
keys caption pick one Fergie and then
queen of all ill-received anthems yep
Roseanne waiting tweeting I think mine
was better
[Music]
today Fergie tells ZT quote I'm a
risk-taker artistically but clearly this
rendition didn't strike the intended
tone last night she proudly posed with
her dad and stars including cardi B and
Black Panthers Michael B Jordan who was
having a better weekend breaking records
I'm so happy I saw that you were
sneaking into theaters what was the
reaction like I mean honestly it was
everybody was laughing you know it was
the yelling at the screen it was cool to
kind of see it with a you know seeing a
normal audience not had a premiere it
was good to see your entourage is thick
Jamie Foxx was with his eight-year-old
daughter Annalise and friends fresh off
playing his version of love and
basketball on Valentine's Day with
undercover girlfriend Katie Holmes did
you practice at all cuz I think I saw a
picture of you with a basketball this
one ready made I don't need to practice
all you got to do I'm ready made all you
gonna do is add water of course Jamie
played it coy not so much on ESPN the
Julianne Katie Holmes played basketball
for Valentine's Day like some real
loving basketball game well some star
couples and parents had a blast Justin
Hartley brought his wife krischell and
daughter Isabella and check out mama
Beyonce
front row taking selfies with a braided
Blue Ivy Kevin Hart had his own family
cheering section but in the tunnel keV
was acting a fool with Ludacris also
weakest Sinaiticus man we wouldn't have
it any other way
[Music]